tell us a little bit about
the trajectory you have had so that so
that we get a sense of of how you moved
from a solidly middle-class background
through being the CEO of palm and and
getting and growing your wealth base how
did that happen and and is there a
connection to you being an entrepreneur
to your views about inherited wealth
well sure there's there's definitely a
connection there i mean i mean my story
is i went i came to Yale I had never
really been exposed to education like
this I went to a very poor public high
school where I did not get a good
education where was that in Benton
Harbor Michigan and I came here totally
unprepared for the academic rigor of
Yale not like you guys today where you
get so much great prep to come here I I
was really it was a struggle for me in
my first couple of years here to figure
out how to study and how to write papers
and all those kind of things but I just
thrived in it I just loved it I loved
this place I loved everything I could
learn from it and then I went out into
the working world for a couple years I
went to a bank in Philadelphia as a
trainee and loved the business world and
decided that's where I wanted to focus I
went back to business school at Harvard
and got my MBA and I wasn't really sure
what I wanted to do I had been in the
bank and I'd seen entrepreneurs in
action and I got kind of excited then
about entrepreneurship it was a mainly
cable TV systems it was you probably
can't relate to this but in the very
very beginning of cable TV when they
were just installing it was a very
entrepreneurial venture small guys doing
it town by town by town and I was
financing them so I got to know them and
really appreciate them and I decided
that I was really interested in
entrepreneurial activities and then
Apple computer came to campus to recruit
the first time they ever came to Harvard
Business School they were interviewing
for technical people I was not a
technical person so they didn't accept
me for an interview but I went and sat
outside the interview room all day and
every time the interviewer came
out and said you know hi introduce
myself to her and say I'm here to see
you and she said well you're not on my
schedule and I'd say I know but I need
to talk to you because I really need to
come work for Apple so by the end of the
day she agreed to sit down and talk to
me and I ended up being the only person
who was hired from the Harvard Business
School to go to apples so it was kind of
interesting and I ended up in a
logistics role in operations where I
won't go through all the details because
it goes on and on but I just I loved the
fast pace i love the innovation i loved
it was a crazy time at apple i mean just
hyper growth and i got responsibilities
very quickly and just really got a taste
for on the entrepreneurial and
innovative and product innovation all
those things so i wanted to stick with
that when I left Apple I took a year off
and and decided that I really wanted to
try to run something I felt like I had
the skills to be a CEO I wanted to try
to be a CEO and I came back specifically
looking for a CEO opportunity in a very
small start-up and that's when I met my
business partner Jeff who I'm now on my
third company with and as co-founder pom
and then you know back to kind of circle
back to the wealth question you know
joining a start-up and getting a a piece
of it is certainly how you have an
opportunity to build wealth so now I was
hired at palm as the CEO so I got kind
of a percentage as a CEO and then in our
second company I was a co-founder so I
had a significantly higher percentage of
the second company as a co-founder and
then ironically enough we sold the
second company back to the first company
and I ended up with more of Palm the
second time around that I had the first
time around which I always loved but
yeah that's that's how it happened and
then you know the company went public
and did well and so I did well and
that's a story